May I have your attention please?
We have made a stop because of bad weather between Shin-Nihombashi and Bakurocho.
Our train cannot continue beyond Nakano.
We apologize for the delay.
May I have your attention please?
Our train is going slowly for safety confirmation near Nakano.
We will resume our travel soon.
Thank you for waiting.
May I have your attention please?
We have made a stop because of a signal failure between Ninomiya and Kouzu.
We apologize for the delay.
May I have your attention please?
Our train is going slowly because of a wayside fire between Monoi and Nishi-Funabashi.
We expect to start at 2:55.
Our train cannot continue beyond Urawa.
We apologize for the delay.
May I have your attention please?
Our train is going slowly because another train is passing.
We expect to start at 4:40.
Our train cannot continue beyond Nishi-Oi.
We apologize for the delay.